new this morning
non-lethal Force you hear that term a
lot but what is it well pepper spray
certainly one option but just like
anything else it takes a little practice
to make sure you know what you're doing
that's right so now you can do just that
you can practice with a new form of that
non-lethal uh protection Candace Charles
is live at a range at Valley View and
Russell with a closer look Candace good
morning to you
good morning to good morning folks yes
this is the Byron Tech products right
over here it's with local police
stations are starting to consider using
and 300 police stations throughout the
country are already using it's fairly
simple to use you don't need a permit
for it in many states and if you do miss
your target you'll likely still get them
you don't have to be up and close
personal on them either so that
definitely makes it easier for civilians
to use that Luan Fawn here with me thank
you so much for joining us tell us our
local law enforcements have been
discussing using this product and how
police stations are already using it
yeah so we sell to a lot of civilians
but are getting attention with
government agencies police departments
across the country not only for the ease
of use the distance effective distance
that our products have over an electric
stun gun 20 feet versus 60 feet We
Believe safety is distance to safety and
if we can give that officer more range
to operate he is going to have a better
outcome than if he had you know less
qualified equipment and then shorter
distance no like I said you have a lot
of different products here this is
something I think the civilians use a
lot
police officers are always also using
this security officers as well as well
as this one what is the difference here
sure there are a variety of launchers
offer the law enforcement officer the
ability to carry it on a service belt
and so size is everything and this is
extremely comfortable and it's familiar
it's the shape of a pistol in situations
where they have to have control a crowd
of folks then this tactical combat rifle
or technical combat Rifle allows them to
operate using higher capacity and
greater range okay okay well it
definitely seems a lot more effective
and less lethal and I think that's the
most important part thank you so much
love for talking to us today and you
guys will find out more details about
Byron Tech on our website newsnow.com
again you do not need a permit for
something like this it starts about 250
just for the gun if you want to go ahead
and get the whole kit including the
little pepper spray inside of the pepper
spray launcher you can range about 350
to 400 we'll have all those details on
our website newsnow.com for now live
from Byron Tech Inc I'm Candace Charles
8 news now I'm certainly a very
interesting product no doubt definitely
all right thanks Candace